ce conseil municipal est un conseil
particulier une page de l'histoire de
notre commune se
tourne après 35 ans de dévouement
Jacques lolios a choisi de permettre le
renouvellement dans la stabilité et la
continuité Bertrand ouon a été élu maire
de manilé am lors d'un conseil municipal
exceptionnel vendredi 28 septembre après
qu mandats Jacques lolios a décidé de
démissionner pour laisser sa place à un
ancien maire adjoint pour moi il est
important que donc on puisse euh passer
donc à une autre génération euh de
quelqu'un qui avait effectivement donc
la bonne connaissance donc de la ville
et euh parce que donc être maire donc
vous savez c'est 6 ans 6 ans c'est court
et c'est long la fois si on veut
réaliser il faut donc
s'orienter parce que c'est comme ça il
faut s'orienter sur voà au minimum de
mandat donc Bertrand vu son âge à 36 ans
et il est en capacité de pouvoir
poursuivre effectivement cette activité
si effectivement euh les manquis
manquoises lui donent confiance Jacques
l'olos ne démissionne pas pour des
problèmes de santé mais afin de préparer
les prochaines élections municipales en
mars 2014 Bertrand Ouillon sera le
candidat de gauche les 18 mois à venir
vont être 18 mois de travail de
continuité finalement cette élection euh
on pourrait dire c'est c'est tout
simplement la continuité de notre action
euh on n pas de
changement autre que les personnes au
niveau de l'exécutif et on continue
notre programme euh avec toujours le
même enthousiasme toujours la même
disponibilité de l'ensemble de
l'ensemble de notre équipe majoritaire
du conseil municipal parmi les dossiers
au programme celui de la réhabilitation
par l'opivoie des logements du quartier
du Buisson mais aussi la continuité des
circulations douces le nouveau maire
s'engage à défendre les services publics
et notamment la Poste qui menace de
supprimer le service de tri et de
distribution sur la ville lors de ce
conseil exceptionnel Bertrand Ouillon a
vite endossé son rôle de maire pour
remettre la médaille d'or de la ville à
Jacques lolos au-delà de l'émotion de la
gauche l'absence de l'opposition s'est
fait remarquer aucun des 5 conseillers
municipaux de l'opposition n'étai
présent vendredi soir qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire c'est ça la démocratie c'est
ça la démocratie donc donc il y a une
convocation du conseil municipal pour le
nouveau maire et donc ces gens donc se
déposent complètement ça veut dire que
finalement il n'accepent pas finalement
qu'il y ait une majorité donc au niveau
d'un conseil municipal il n'accepte pas
qu'il puisse y avoir des changements un
dé de démocratie à son tour évoqué par
le collectif manie nouvelleénergie dans
un communiqué manie nouvelleénergie
collectif visant au renouveau politique
de maniléamo dénonce un véritable dénis
de démocratie et rappelle à Jacques Lolo
Bertrand Houillon et l'ensemble de
l'actuelle majorité de gauche que les
seuls qui trancheront seront les
manicois et manicoises en mars 2014 lors
des élections municipales outre le maire
un nouvel adjoint a été élu à
l'urbanisme et au logement jeentanerel
est devenu le 8e adjoint de Bertrand
Ouillon